i'm tim ferriss author entrepreneur
angel investor and now tv host
i've spent my entire adult life asking
questions then scouring the globe to
find the answers
on this show i'll share the secrets of
pioneers who have faced their own fears
we'll dig into the hard times big
mistakes tough decisions and how they
got through it all
the goal isn't to be fearless the goal
is to learn to fear less
[Music]
welcome to fearless i'm your host tim
ferriss and on this stage we'll be
deconstructing world-class performers of
all different types to uncover the
specific tactics and strategies they've
used to overcome doubt tackle their
hardest decisions and ultimately succeed
on their own terms by show of hands
how many of you guys own a few pairs of
shoes
that is everybody in the room how many
of you own around 10 pairs of shoes
all right more than half how many of you
do not own a single pair of shoes
all right that's a big fat zero my guest
tonight has built a company that's given
away more than 60 million pairs of shoes
to those who need them most during a
trip to south america he recognized the
unique opportunity to blend business and
philanthropy since its founding thomas
has given away millions of shoes helped
to store eyesight and provided safe
drinking water to those in need across
the globe so ladies and gentlemen please
welcome to the stage the founder of
tom's blake mykoski
[Applause]
[Music]
it's been a few years man yeah
so
blake and i met
quite a while back and we'll get to sort
of the origin stories of all that but i
thought what we could do is take a look
at one of the ways that i was not
necessarily introduced to but
reacquainted with tom so we have a video
that we're going to start with okay
great
[Music]
it's incredible to think that five years
ago what has now become a global event
started with a simple idea on a college
campus
i'm going without shoes so i can know
what millions of children go through
every day
[Music]
you don't really realize what a luxury
we have to have shoes on our feet all
day ah it's actually kind of painful
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so why would i start with this video
well there are a few reasons the first
is that clearly i think it puts in
perspective as one event
the good that blake and his company and
all the people involved have done number
two
this is a master of positioning and pr
and events and a lot in between
and we're gonna come back to that and
take a look at how it all came to be but
the apple doesn't seem to fall too far
from the tree butter busters yeah let's
talk about butter busters this is going
somewhere bear with me
what is butterbusters so butterbusters
is a
cookbook that my mom
wrote on a word processor in like 1993
uh
literally in our kitchen that went on to
sell
millions and millions of copies
and it was this crazy experience for me
being 15 years old seeing my mom who was
uh you know that you know married to my
dad he was a doctor he was the
breadwinner all this the next thing you
know she's getting you know royalty
checks for millions of dollars in the
mail because she wrote a book mainly
because she wanted to help people lose
weight and keep their cholesterol down
because she had high cholesterol she had
high cholesterol and so she basically
the story was she went to the doctor
and came home and had high cholesterol
and uh the doctor suggested her cutting
some of the fat out of her diet and uh
and so she started doing that and she
started losing weight as well and she
wanted to share what she learned with
others and i think i learned two things
from that one at that very
impressionable age i saw like my mom had
an idea that could help people and she
acted on it even though she had never
written a thing in her life you know
didn't graduate from college like it you
know just just did it and she didn't
think about it she just acted and the
second thing was is that like you can
start something from nothing and and a
fortune can be made out of out of
literally your kitchen in a typewriter
so did she
go to
a bunch of new york publishers and they
had a auction and one of them bought the
book or how did yeah i mean you'll
appreciate this with your story uh you
know she um
she felt so connected to
helping people and and really reaching
people directly that she didn't even go
down the publishing route she
self-published it and actually the first
time that she published it the publisher
was uh kind of a crook and and her my
dad lost like fifty thousand dollars
which was a ton of money to our family
back then and um and so she got a loan
from the bank to publish it again the
second time and and she started selling
them literally out of our garage and her
big break was she landed the uh sam's
club part of walmart and uh and next
thing you know she was selling hundreds
of thousands of copies and we had to get
a little warehouse next to our house and
we were herself and which turned out to
be a great business thing because she
sold over a million copies before she
had a publisher so
it's a lot of that's a lot of envelopes
yeah
so
you know i
i think it's
i had no idea that's where we're going
to start this conversation but i think
it's actually a wonderful place to start
because it's so many people after you
have had some success as an entrepreneur
asked you you know where did it come
from you know where did the drive come
from and for me you know the drive came
more from my athletic background and all
the lessons i learned trying to be a
professional tennis player but the
understanding of creating something from
nothing and doing it to help people
clearly came from me
seeing this experience at age 15 to 18
uh you know with my mom well let's talk
about smu okay all right so i was only
there for 18 months so right so we we
won't uh spend
too much time on it but you chose
philosophy is that right yeah
my philosophy well i started because um
i originally majored in archaeology
because my goal is to become indiana
jones
that was that was my career path
no i mean it's like i was never really
that into school i was a tennis player
as thing but i thought okay if i don't
become a professional tennis player what
would i want to do with my life
and i was like i think indiana jones is
the best job so what did he study study
archaeology but no one told me and i so
i say i set up all archaeology classes
freshman year and i'm in these classes
and they're more like chemistry and
we're studying like the compounds of
rocks and this i mean it's like boring
stuff in the world so i was like no
whips
no whip still talk about like tribes and
and
cannibals and all the stuff i was
excited about getting into and um or
learning how to stay away from and uh
but but so i dropped out of the
archaeology classes because they were it
was like watching paint dry um
and i thought okay so what else
you know could i could it be interesting
but part of my fascination i think with
indiana jones and this idea of traveling
the world and discovering you know
people and and and ancient ruins and all
this stuff also came with this idea of
understanding like world religions and
how we got you know why some people
think this way and other people think
that way and so then that led to okay
philosophy could be a great place to to
really dig into from an academic
standpoint and learn why people think
different things how you know how
we've evolved as human beings and and so
that was and i found once i got into
philosophy classes i actually really
loved them because they were
pretty quickly into stuff that i felt
like was relatable uh to my experience
as a human and uh and so i i really uh
enjoyed philosophy to this day when i
have time for free reading i read a lot
of philosophy any favorite philosophers
or books descartes i like a lot i would
say is one of my favorites plato
aristotle i mean kind of classic sort of
i mean they've been classics for
hundreds of years for a reason right and
so i feel like you can find you know you
can you can read some aristotle and it's
literally like as relevant as as another
book you might read to improve some part
of your life today for sure yeah i've
been infatuated with and obsessed with
the stoic philosophers yeah that was two
thousand plus years ago in some cases
with marcus really marcus realized i
mean i mean meditations that book
is like i mean if you really allow
yourself to
slowly read and allow those words and
allow those phrases to be like imprinted
in your mind i mean that book has more
you could read only that book and have
all the wisdom you need probably to live
a
a virtuous a successful a adventurous
life i mean that's one of my favorite
books of all time so meditation is just
to put it in perspective for folks so
meditations was written by marcus
aurelius at the time
the emperor of rome so he's the most
powerful man in the world and they are
effectively entries in a war journal so
they were never intended to be published
so it's his notes to himself which makes
it very interesting
and actually on that point
do you have a journaling habit i do
when did you start that i was about 15
and and why did you start doing that
kind of goes back to tennis i wanted to
chart my progress like that's how that's
how focused i was i wanted to understand
if i was really getting better and i had
read when i was young about other
successful athletes that part of what
they did was they journaled and they
wrote positive affirmations you know
kind of pregame but but journaling it it
was more imprinted in their mind and i
started and it's fun to go back and read
some of those journals uh when i was 15
like how serious i was as a 15 year old
it's all a little scary um but uh but
yeah i started then and then very
quickly it became um a form of kind of
therapy for me you know as an as an
early entrepreneur when you know things
were really tough and and you didn't if
you're gonna make payroll and you didn't
have anyone you didn't want to tell
anyone because you always had to show
this air of confidence and everything's
going to be great so then at night i
could be scribbling about how how
concerned i was and and kind of
confessing a lot of things that were
bothering me or i was worried about and
uh in journaling has been um probably
the most constant
um habit in my life i mean i do it every
single morning
sometimes twice a day but it's
interesting one of the things i always
say to people about journaling is i
think it's one of the most powerful
habits you can create because a lot of
the journaling too is goal setting and
and and really you know having the goals
and then writing about how you're trying
to achieve them and then going back and
seeing which ones you're achieving and
which ones you're not and kind of
understanding that but the other thing
is you can learn so much about
the things that end up working and not
working you can kind of go back and see
you know
you know what led to the success or the
failure of that idea through kind of the
journal path and you can also see that
things that you thought were so
important end up not being at all
especially with girlfriends and things
like that in the early days i mean so
it's it's really interesting i think you
can learn a lot from from journaling um
and it's something that i i i tell you
know people all the time like there's
one thing that can kind of help get your
life on a more positive path uh
journaling is it so this is going to be
a bit of a left turn from
from journaling easy laundry yes
tell me all about it so easy laundry
well easy laundry i guess was my first
real business
i'm playing tennis you know like chasing
my dreams at smu i partially tear my
achilles tendon so that injury is
six to eight months leg cast like and
already i was the last guy on the team
so eight months of no playing and new
freshmen that are more talented coming
in like i started to realize like maybe
my life you know path is not
to be a professional tennis player it
wasn't until a couple weeks later when
my roommate and i were discussing my
huge pile of laundry that was growing in
our room because i couldn't do it
because i was on crutches and so the
laundry facility is down in the basement
and i'm on crutches
and uh and so it was kind of piling up
and and and this is back in hard to
believe when we looked in the yellow
pages for stuff right you remember that
some people listening or here today
might not remember the internet yeah of
yesteryear yeah yeah so
so i looked in the yellow pages um
for someone to pick up my laundry and
this was lowest google ever by the way
yeah
and uh and so it's um
there's there's nothing that does that
and uh my laundry's piling up so it's a
real problem and i think this is where a
lot of entrepreneur ideas are born out
of necessity out of some service you
want that's not offered right and so i
went to school at smu as a private
school in dallas and there were a lot of
you know kids who had plenty of
disposable income and didn't like doing
their laundry too so i thought what if
we had this pickup and delivery laundry
service we called it easy laundry and
the idea is is that we would we would
basically pick up the laundry take it to
a facility do a you know get a bulk rate
with them and then deliver it back the
next day or two days later
was it true that you guys would do fake
deliveries to dorms to try to create the
illusion of having a successful business
to drum up demand this is true okay so
can you
just describe how that worked
so no one wanted to kind of be first and
be like oh i'm too lazy to do my own
laundry i'm gonna have someone else do
it or i'm gonna you know i mean i don't
for whatever reason the the the
psychological
uh kind of um
herd mentality in college is very strong
and so we kind of somehow know how we
realized this but we did we thought okay
if we start
delivering even though we don't need to
deliver all day long and all people see
is ours as our truck driving around
campus and me or our employees going
into into dorms out of dorms they're
going to think everyone's doing this and
they're missing out you know and and
that and that also led to more customers
because they're like man i see your
truck everywhere yeah business is great
and business did become great because
they thought that that man if everyone
else is doing this service then i should
be doing it too so that worked pretty
well and they really did and by the way
this is not uncommon at all no i mean so
case in point
benjamin franklin so most people think
of him for you know the kite with the
key and so on whatever it might be
diplomat maybe who knows but
he was very famous as a printer
and in the beginning days to try to drum
up business he would go up and down the
street with a wheelbarrow full of all
sorts of different printing equipment
back and forth to show how busy he was
to try to get people to come in
and uh and to drum up business
turned out very well for you i mean well
it's i think it's such an important
point because
the best
ideas
and the best companies that start always
come from an entrepreneur who
wants a service that he can't get a
product that doesn't exist you know it's
it's a frustration you know and it and
and and the solution is not a business
actually it's like a crusade to to get
rid of that frustration and it really is
and so i always caution people say you
can study entrepreneurship and you can
read books about great entrepreneurs but
if you think you're going to build a
great company it's got to start with a
dissatisfaction a problem an it's you
want to scratch first and then you build
the business but don't think about okay
i want to build a business what am i
going to build so what happened
you 18 months that your 10 year was up
yeah well i think what happened was is
is all of a sudden we had so much demand
for this laundry service we started and
we had customers and you know not just
at smu but we we started to expand the
university of texas uh tcu university
oklahoma uh and it was clear that there
was all this demand and i was like
trying to do my homework at you know at
night running the business during the
day i think we had 30 employees at that
point i mean it was just was it was just
too much but uh but yeah i dropped out
and uh there were so many days after i
did i was like oh my god i want to go
back to college so bad so easy you know
because like all my friends are like you
know going to a few classes and drinking
beer and goofing off and i'm like
dealing with these 15 people's lost
jeans every week and um and so uh it
wasn't glamorous by any means uh it's
only glamorous in hindsight when you're
like yeah it's a college dropout you
know bill gates is a dropout you know
michael dell's i mean it's kind of a
nice badge to have now but it definitely
wasn't then i have to ask because i
honestly don't know the answer how did
reality tv come into all this in 2001 my
sister and i were on the tv show the
amazing race i was
25 at the time
and this was like the beginning of the
reality tv craze that we're still
frankly in i mean it's hard to believe
all these years later
and and really this 15 minutes of fame i
mean this is a real thing so all of a
sudden like we're being invited to be on
you know all these talk shows late night
shows jay leno invited you know will
smith's birthday party i mean just this
weird stuff right because everyone was
watching the show and we were like we
really one of the interesting characters
on the show
and what i found was as i was thinking
about you know this fact this thing
was that like
after the 15 minutes they moved on to
the next season there was still value
and the entertainment value in the
public's interest in these people the
networks had to move to the next one
because it was time to you know it was
time to promote the next show
so my idea was
is why not have a cable television
network that would be 100 focused on
reality and now i knew we couldn't get
the big ticket shows but i knew we could
get the stars after because there's
nothing worse than losing your 15
minutes of fame you'll do anything to
keep it going right
so i can get these people to come on
shows for nothing just for their own you
know be excited people to be interested
in them still and then possibly you
could even create shows that are like
you know based off the characters and
then we could what i knew we could do is
we could buy clips of the shows the part
that i didn't know anything about and
which reason this business became a huge
disaster was
there's only five or six companies in
the country that controlled the
distribution of the content and so when
we went to you know comcast and time
warner and directv and all the different
ones and they're like well we have 500
channels right now is your channel even
if people love your channel it's not
going to change our business but we're
going to have to pay you for this
content so we're not that interested and
it was amazing to me it's such a great
business lesson that we had a product
that the end customer wanted and we
could make amazing content that they
actually really probably cared more
about than the other 420 channels but
because the person who is controlling
what they saw didn't have a business
reason to do it we could never make it
work and so after you know a couple hard
years and running through millions of
dollars and many a lot of it is my own
money we had to go out of business but i
wasn't done even though i shut it down
and paid back investors and fired 40
something people which was you know
horrible i wanted to continue to go and
so i kind of went into a the first and
only time in my life where i've had
actually some real depression and got on
like antidepressants and like things
that i never thought in my life i would
experience it wasn't because of so much
that we had failed and that we had lost
money and we had to fire people and all
that it was because like i still wanted
to do this but i couldn't like it was
like it was not i couldn't like solve a
new way to do it and so that was a tough
you know four or five uh months
afterwards which i ultimately got
through but um but man what a great
lesson i mean the thing is where were
you at the time you're in l.a i was in
l.a and so the it's i think the lesson
is you're thinking about business ideas
is definitely when i think about any new
thing even within toms now
is like
no matter how good your idea is
you have to make sure
that you if it if
your success is falls in the hands of a
few companies
that you don't even start to go forward
unless you can make sure that at least
you get one of those companies as a
customer yeah because if and that's why
i think it was so great when we started
toms and shoe business or apparel or
whatever like there's thousands of
stores that could potentially buy your
shoes so the other thing i had to get
one of the big guys early on you know
you could just get a couple and then
build from there yeah you do risk it
yeah a whole lot now i want to come back
to if you don't mind just that period of
depression so
i've had extended bouts of depression
runs in my family
and not going to blame it on that but
that's probably a component
what was it like in your darkest periods
during those five months i think the
hardest thing was is like not wanting to
get out of bed yeah like i'm a very
energetic person i like usually jump out
of bed with both feet on the floor well
before the sun has come up my whole
entrepreneurial life and like
not having a business to go to having
just kind of lost a lot of credibility
with potential investors or you know
because i was now you know failed
entrepreneur not just a successful
entrepreneur and having run through a
lot of my own financial resources like
it was like what am i going to do today
what what did bring you out of it i mean
what were the things that helped
get you back on your feet at the time i
was reading a lot of richard branson's
stuff and i was i read losing my
virginity which is a great group you've
never read one of the books that sort of
kick-started me yeah it was just i was
like and i loved his approach to taking
like
businesses that had been around forever
and turning them on their head by
basically just making them fun sarcastic
sexy etc and so i looked at the driver's
ed business and this is something been
around since my my parents learned to
drive right and they were brick and
mortar buildings they were usually
connected to like a sears or something
and and and and they didn't try to
um accommodate their students they just
like pushed them through this like
cattle
so i did two things i it's called
driver's ed direct and this is how i got
the swagger back because i i really
excited about this idea for a number of
reasons uh the first was is we were
gonna have no classrooms so we're just
gonna eliminate that cost and all the
class work would be online now they
would have to learn to drive in a car
but the online pro they would make it
fun and we'd do it online and we would
make sure they were paying attention
because they couldn't get to the next
part of the class until they passed real
time quizzes but the second thing i did
and this is what i think was the thing
that really made it take off
is i recognize los angeles you have a
lot of models and actors that need
part-time work and they need flexible
schedules instead of these teenagers
learning from old ladies what if they're
learning from abercrombie and fitch
models that's going to keep a teenage
girl's attention right i mean if this
girl has this hunky guy yeah you know
teaching her to drive she's going to pay
attention to him and she's going to tell
all her friends on myspace how hot her
driver's ed teacher is
and it's the same thing for the guys and
so we hired like the hottest models and
actors who needed part-time work in
between editions we were totally
flexible with their hours and and it
went fire we went crazy on myspace i
mean every kid is like you i mean i
think people signed up had already
completed driver's day just because they
i mean it was like
it was crazy
so we talked about drivers at direct
yeah
then in 2006
you went to one of my favorite places
place you know well argentina yeah
why'd you go to argentina
i would take the month of january off
every year no matter what no matter what
was going on business-wise i would take
a month i would go somewhere that was
totally different have a totally new
cultural experience get away from work
and then come back and then just immerse
myself for 11 more months and have that
month to look forward to and so i
decided that for my month this year
in 2006 i would go to argentina one
thing that i had already noticed and
already had a big impression on me and
this started when we were on the amazing
race but even more so in argentina was
just how much poverty there was only an
hour outside the city and i mean there
were you know kids on the street not
wearing shoes shantytown shantytown
millionaire exactly i mean it's exactly
what it looks like you know people
living in homes built of aluminum siding
no electricity no water i mean it was i
just i couldn't believe it and it was on
the third week that i was there
that i was in this cafe this wine cafe
and i heard some women speaking in
english and they had been doing
volunteer work they were working with
this non-profit in argentina and one of
the things that they were doing was a
shoe drive
and they explained to me that uh it was
getting time about time for school again
the next semester and there were many
kids that uh
were not able to go to school because
they couldn't afford the uniform or the
shoes and shoes was part of the uniform
they had to wear a closed-toe shoe
and so i agreed to go on this on this on
this trip and they picked me up a couple
days later and we got in a van and we
had a big u-haul full of shoes and we
went to this this town
and at first not having ever done
anything like this i was a little bit
just kind of standing back and watching
and why and and these girls they were
just right on their hands and knees and
putting shoes on kids and giving them
hugs and it was just like this joyful
thing so i very quickly just jumped in
and started trying to figure it out and
i remember that night i came home
i'm staying at the polo camp still and
uh my polo teacher alejo um he asked me
where was it day because i wasn't
playing polo and i said why actually i
did this and he's like did that on your
vacation and he says to me he says you
know blake
it's awesome that you guys gave him
shoes and but you're leaving like in
five more days and these women are going
back to their countries like who's going
to give them their next pair
and i was never prepared for this
question and when he asked this question
because he's like you know kids feet are
going to grow fast or they're going to
only pair their wear out of them and if
they need them for school
you know you've now given this pair but
who's going to give them the next pair
and at that point i actually questioned
whether we had done anything good at all
like maybe what we did that day was just
made ourselves feel great because we got
this great you know kind of feeling and
oh my gosh we did something nice for
someone and they loved on us and we left
feeling so full
but if we just set up a future you know
disappointment like we'd actually caused
more harm than good if there wasn't a
way to sustain these kids in shoes and
so talk about like some difficult
moments in life i remember going to bed
that night like having kind of that joy
and excitement almost ripped out of me
and thinking gosh this is like like this
is this
i don't know what the answer is but
there's got to be something a way to to
to to make sure these kids get their
next pair of shoes and so the next
morning woke up got the journal out
have my cup of coffee sitting on the
farm uh where the polo camp was and i
was just writing you know in my journal
and i was saying you know maybe i could
go and ask all my friends to donate you
know 50 bucks a year and that would buy
four pairs of shoes and that way every
every three months they get a new pair
or we all have too many shoes in our
closet right i mean i'm sure we could
all get rid of half of our shoes and we
would not have any effect on our life
whatsoever maybe i could get those and i
started thinking about adult sizes or
different kids sizes and all these
things and
and i just i i just quickly got to the
part of like i don't think charity is
the answer like i don't think asking for
donations or handouts is really going to
sustain this now this might work for a
year or two but then it's going to be
even a bigger problem if i don't get the
donations or don't get the handouts
and then that's when not only that you
have to spend all your time fundraising
and not focusing on building out the
organization and so on well yes but at
this point i'm not even thinking about
an organization i'm thinking about 250
kids yeah i mean that's my only that's i
mean i'm only emotionally connected to
250 kids not in the world thinking about
anyone else or the fact that there's
kids in cambodia they don't have shoes
or kids that have frostbite and mangolia
or kids that have potoconiosis in
ethiopia i mean i know nothing about any
of this at that point but i do care
about these 250 kids i spent all day
with them i connected with them i i i
saw the joy that they got and so
so in my journal that morning i just
turned in a pretty natural
flow to business like every of my life
for 10 years i mean i'm now 29 years old
so i've been i've been entrepreneur for
10 years and i had used business to
solve problems like that's the way i
looked at entrepreneurship something i
don't like as we were talking about
earlier or something that i don't think
is fair or right in the world let's see
if we can change it with business and so
i was just writing an eyebrow i said you
know what if we started a a actual
business that had a very simple model
you sold shoes to people who wanted them
and you gave shoes to people who needed
them and and uh we caught one for one
and that was just it was like you know
just literally this much of one of
hundreds of journals
but as i'm finishing that thought
the the great alejo and this is he's one
of the greatest human beings you'll ever
meet most enthusiastic people i've ever
met
comes up and he and he says it's time
for breakfast before the polo match says
you're running late let's go let's go
and i said no leo i think i have an
answer to your question
i said you know instead of a charity
what if there was a business that sold
these shoes that you guys all wear here
in argentina and that we don't have in
the united states
yeah hey opera godzilla's i mean you
remember when you were there and every
time we sell a pair we give a pair
and over a month we got the first it was
250 pairs were the initial prototypes
because there were 250 kids in this
village that we wanted to come give
another pair to after we sold them and
we stuffed them in three duffle bags we
bought at the at the local you know kind
of equivalent of foot locker and put
them in you know checked them and got
through custom somehow without getting
confiscated or you know and uh and and
and and literally got him back to la to
my apartment in venice how did you get
your first retailer your first key
retailer if that makes sense so
i was going just cold calling these
stores when i found out really quickly
if you emailed or called a store and
said you wanted to sell them shoes that
they didn't know anything about the
brand you never got a response
you had to go there in person so i was
going in person and but very often i was
going to person on the weekends because
during the week i'm running the driver's
ed company still and so there aren't
usually shoe buyers working on the
weekends it's just staff but luckily i
got on on american rag on a saturday i
got courtney was working that day and so
she's like yeah i'll look at it whatever
and she was a pretty curious kind of
cool interesting person um and i started
the shoes and even before i got to the
story she kind of thought this is kind
of cool like this is they're a very
progressive fashion retailer they like
the new thing and she's like i'll buy
she said how much inventory do you have
and i was like well i got like 210 pairs
left i had sold like 40 to friends and
family a couple online you know had a
little rinky dinky website that like my
you know parents would be ordering from
from texas and stuff and um
and so uh but she's like i need a way to
tell the story and so we i showed her a
picture and
we put it and she put it like by the
display and on a piece of cardboard we
wrote what we thought was our kind of
mission and that was with every pair you
purchased we will give a pair to a child
in need one for one we put that there
and um
and she bought i think 85 pairs which
was like a third of my inventory which i
was super excited about and um and the
funny thing about that and i mean that
led to so many other things but the main
thing that led to
was a woman from l.a times saw
these shoes and saw on the cardboard
that we were going to give away a pair
of fairy prairie soul and this woman's
name is booth moore
and at the time she was the leading
fashion writer at l.a times and one of
the most syndicated fashion writers in
the world i mean everyone read her
columns
and so she asked courtney for my
information and courtney gave it to me
and
i did the interview and was like super
excited and and and and but i didn't
really have a idea of like what this
would potentially do to what we were
calling this as a time as a project we'd
even call it a business it was the tom's
project you know because i had a
business was the driver's ed business
this was the project and so i didn't
know what was going to happen with the
project when this article came out but
two weeks after the interview
on the cover of the la times there were
two headlines this is the calendar
section it was da vinci code opens with
300 million in box office sales which
you know people in la care about these
things and then the second thing is uh
tom's shoes
this and this we sold
2200 pairs on our website before noon
that day
now i only had 130 pairs in my apartment
so like this is the first of many
supplies this is the good news bad news
yeah this is the good news bad news
so
i mean it was like it was crazy had this
little article in a big article had this
response of people in los angeles to go
on this little tiny website and and
somehow trust it and buy shoes and then
the website said you would get your
shoes in four to five days because we
you know we're just shipping them out of
my apartment one at a time
so now i have you know an order for 2200
we've already charged these people's
credit card by the way because it just
automatically goes through i have no
idea if alejo and juan can make these
shoes i mean i don't even think they
think they're going to see me again and
so i literally landed the airport i've
got a little duffel bag like toiletries
maybe two things to close in the la
times and i take a taxi directly to
juan's house they're both there you know
drinking their mate like everyone does
in argentina just totally chilled out
like they like no problems in the world
and i might come in like you know bad
out of hell and i'm like
muchos zapatos rapido
that's all the spanish i knew and that's
all the spanish i needed and i showed
them that article and they just couldn't
believe it and so one calls his friend
and a friend and next thing you know
there's like all these different
argentines making these shoes as fast as
they can in their garages which
ultimately became a barn just became our
first factory down there two weeks later
um and let me just preface this with
because it's important to understand uh
get a picture of what our apartment's
like at the time so we have this
apartment in venice um and i have three
interns so two weeks after that article
comes out i'm walking by it was in the
kitchen walking by the kitchen area and
phone rings so i pick it up and say
hello this is blake tom's shoes
and there's this guy on the airline
and you can tell he's a little bit
agitated from the first minute he says
yes yes um i need to order a hundred
pairs of women's toms i need red i need
blue i need natural and i need them to
go out tomorrow
now i'm like whoa like i mean we've had
people maybe order two or three pairs
but a hundred pairs one person this is
like not this doesn't make sense because
all we're doing is selling online at
this point and and i said well gosh
first off like this is amazing 100 pairs
like who is this like where are you
calling from he says oh yes i'm the
assistant women's shoe buyer at
nordstrom in seattle at the corporate
office now i don't know a lot about
shoes but i know that nordstrom is like
the holy grail of shoes at this point
like people been talking to me about
nordstrom nordstrom and i know that like
they don't call you at your apartment
like it takes like you beg to get a
meeting with these guys right so i'm a
little bit like is this really this is a
prank but i can tell this guy's like
really focused on on on this order and
so as i'm thinking about this i realize
you know we have no shoes right we sold
out so i said to the guy i'm like okay
this is awesome 100 pairs we could do
that it's probably about two or three
weeks he's like no no i need them
tomorrow like my boss wants them
yesterday i need them tomorrow and i'm
like well we're sold out
and he goes no you can't be sold just
bump someone else's order like this is
nordstrom calling like no one tells us
we're sold out
so i'm like okay sir but like i don't
think you really understand the
situation like i'm not i can't bump
someone else's order like i literally
don't have any shoes to send you at this
point the guy gets pissed off
and he goes this is what he says to me
he goes and my phone's like you know
about to start beeping and he's like he
goes listen buddy if you can't help me
put me in touch with the sales
department
[Laughter]
so
for the bet
but the best part of this whole thing is
while this conversation's going on my
three interns are sitting there eating
breakfast tacos that they just got from
rose cafe
and one of the girls lina is like
laughing because she can overhear this
conversation
and and after that i didn't really know
what to say and so she's like give me
the phone give me the phone so i
literally it's about to start beeping so
i just toss it to her anyways and
without even i this was my favorite
moments in the history of toms without
even blinking or hesitating she just
goes hi this is lena head of sales
so
we're going to pull up a photo of early
days
some toms i think in one of your
original apartments i have a funny story
about these bags too let's hear about
the bags so these bags almost sunk the
company
literally
we were almost out of business because
of the bags
so
and most people don't know this and i'm
glad you showed this picture because
it's something that never comes up in
interviews
i actually had two big ideas with toms
the first idea is that we were going to
give a pair to a kid for every pair we
sold and we were going to help kids in
argentina who needed shoes to go to
school
that's the idea that became famous that
people know us for the second idea is we
were going to be the first shoe company
to eliminate the horrible waste of
cardboard boxes
think about when you buy a pair of shoes
what do you do with the box you throw it
away and most of you probably don't even
recycle it i mean it is hard you know
it's not easy to recycle sometimes and
especially 10 years ago very few people
were recycling stuff like boxes and i
hated the fact that there was so much
waste being created by the shoe industry
and so i got these recyclable you know
bags linen bags that were made of
materials that could be repurposed and
also it could be used for something you
could put stuff in it and whatnot and so
we were going to be the first company to
only use bags
so that worked great when our initial
sales were online because someone would
order a pair you stick the bag in the in
the in the box or the fedex envelope or
whatever you sent and you sent it and
you did not have to waste another box
but then when we got into nordstrom they
said okay i mean this is we're starting
some press we're in vogue it's exciting
like you know they're like okay we're in
we're gonna give it a shot we'll give
you five stores southern california and
um they said uh but we need boxes and i
was like no there are no boxes and
they're like
yeah but that's you understand like the
way that our business works is we have
stock rooms and every brand gets a stock
room and they have boxes by size and so
when someone wants a seven they come and
get a seven
it won't work with bags and i'm like
well then we're not gonna do business
and they're like what and i'm like well
we're we're not gonna create waste in
the world with these boxes so we're
gonna use bags and the buyer was just
like first off i don't think anyone ever
told nordstrom like they're just not
gonna do business but i mean i once
again i wasn't thinking of it like a
business and i was and i was adamant
about this bad thing because i was
getting really good feedback because
like people love the fact that i mean
they connected with this idea so anyway
so
the guy who was a buyer said fine like
we're we'll try it i mean but i'm
telling you this is going to be really
really hard to stack bags
and and if our associates who make money
on commission have trouble getting your
shoes they won't sell as well i was like
well let's just give it a shot so
the first week it's actually pretty easy
to stack backs our sales the first week
you're like doing great like i'm calling
i'm like so excited whatever
second week it's like an abrupt halt i
mean not i don't think a pair sells and
i'm like what happened and he goes go to
you know la brea nordstrom and look in
the stock room i go in there it's a
tangled mess because each bag has a
string and then a tag on it and they get
caught and i mean literally you can't
pull these bags apart so now when the
customer comes in says i want size seven
the person is not going to waste their
time and lose commission they're like
well how about a pair of vans instead
right you know or we're sold out that
was the thing everyone's saying right
they're sold out i mean they're not sold
out they're in there and so literally
nordstrom said um until you get boxes
like no more business and so we actually
got kicked out of nordstrom's it took us
about six months or so before we finally
got into like boxes because it wasn't
just so easy like getting in the old box
you want to design the box and all this
and so literally
it's like it's so interesting because i
feel like in business you breaking rules
sometimes leads to innovation and new
companies and all these things but you
gotta know which rules to break because
there's some rules that you just can't
break and i mean we have boxes today so
so
you know i mean it's funny those early
memories are so great but it and it but
hopefully it shows other entrepreneurs
and people thinking about businesses
like they all start you know in a garage
in an apartment with an idea with a
group of people who believe in it before
anyone else you struggle with all these
crazy things and then if you just keep
at it long enough enough good things
start happening so what i want to do we
we have there's so many things we could
go for a five hour talk here but before
we do that what i like to do is take
some audience q a great so we have some
questions that were gathered
during the break and so i'm going to
start with as an entrepreneur we all
face fear what was your greatest fear in
business and then part two what does
failure look like to you um that's a
really good question um
so i had different fears of different
businesses but i want to stick to tom's
because i think it was
probably the
the
most motivating fear
um i think sometimes fear can
paralyze you in business or in life and
relationships and sometimes it can be
the greatest motivator and and the
greatest catalyst for success
so i go to argentina after that first
giving trip we've given ten thousand
shoes we originally were trying to do
250 kids so 10 000 is amazing right
but also what i created now is 10 000
kids who need another pair of shoes
so the very problem that i was trying to
alleviate through the business idea
actually was exasperated with that
initial success because i was not
thinking about 10 000 kids when i had
250 shoes made i was thinking
something that seemed very manageable
and that is these 250 kids getting them
shoes but now once we sold and gave away
10 000
i had this i left that trip not as
excited as i should have been i left
thinking oh my gosh i can't let these
communities down like they think we're
coming back in four months and giving
another 10 000 pairs of shoes away so
i've got to make sure that i can sell
these shoes and frankly i didn't know
how i was going to do it i mean we had
had some luck with this media and we got
some momentum but i mean there was no
guarantee that anyone was placing more
orders for 10 000 shoes and so i
remember like i mean i was barely
sleeping i was definitely not healthy in
terms of the hours i was working and it
wasn't because i was loving it or it was
fun or i was having a high from the joy
of the kids i was literally afraid of
having to go back there and be like uh
we don't have any more shoes or we only
sold two thousand pairs so only at 20 of
you get shoes so so so fear really was a
motivator and and it has been in many
different chapters and toms not because
i was afraid of failing as a business
i'd already done that before with my
reality channel but failing other humans
is a much
heavier burden to wear especially when
they have so little and they're
expecting so much so that's really how
fear has been a great motivator for me
uh what are two to three books you can't
live without hmm the four-hour work week
i mean i
i did i did give him a 20 earlier
i uh i didn't have the mental toughness
to get through the four hour body so um
but no i mean all seriousness like that
book was a huge influence as i said
before which i'm super grateful for um
you know i'd say uh
the books that have had the biggest
impact on me in the last few years one
of them is uh it's called the art of
power it's by a vietnamese buddhist monk
named tottenham
and and the great thing about it is it
talks about the d when he's talking
about the art of power it's definitely
not the way we think of power in the
west but really the power of mindfulness
and really of being able to
be present in the moment in everything
that you're doing and i found that that
book which i've read multiple times now
has had a huge a huge huge influence on
just how i try to approach my day
my business
parenting my marriage everything so i
highly recommend uh that book if you if
you haven't read it um meditations we
talked about earlier
marcus aurelius is another really really
great one i think depending on where you
are in your journey i think both of
howard schultz's books are amazing for
entrepreneurs his first book was called
pour your heart into it it's the early
story of starbucks and how it was
created and i think it really
illustrates a lot of amazing things that
entrepreneurs can learn from and then
his second book which was a really
important book for me to read at a point
when which i actually left the business
for a while and then came back to it was
called onward and that was about some of
the struggles that starbucks went
through and and how they kind of rebuilt
the culture in the company in the last
10 years and so i'm really thankful that
howard was so vulnerable and open with
that book because i think it it answered
a lot of questions i was having at the
time uh as as well so those are a couple
of of good ones that i would recommend
and uh note on uh so tiknot han the
vietnamese buddhist monk he was
nominated for the nobel peace prize by
dr martin luther king jr
really fascinating guy and his first
book which was kind of like meditations
in the sense that it wasn't intended to
be a book called i believe it's pieces
every step pieces every step yeah is
fantastic it was actually a guide
intended to be given to new monks and
visitors to his
center in i guess it was at the time
perhaps it was in vietnam he's in france
it's in france right
uh fantastic fantastic book oh one more
just because we're in california and
it's someone i've also looked up and
learned a lot from is and it just came
out with the
i think maybe the 10 or 20th year
anniversary version is yvonne chennard
who started patagonia let my people go
surfing it's it's a fantastic book um
about company culture it also shares
some really tough times in the patagonia
ups and downs that i that i learned a
lot from
and also i think it was interesting
because when he wrote the book 10 years
ago it was kind of the beginning of
internet sales and it really shows how
they did not
they did not risk their business by
having too much of their sales in one
place they have a wholesale business
they have retail stores they have online
they have catalog and that's something
that we've done with toms over the years
is to move away from just online to now
wholesale and now we're spending a lot
of our energy building our own retail
stores
this next one is if you lost everything
today what would you be thankful for
well
i mean
the truth is is it's impossible for me
to lose everything today
because everything that i have
has very little to do with what i have
materially the experiences i've have the
memories i have the friends the family
that's what i have and that literally
can't be taken away so i mean
and
you know no one's really asked me that
question but i could respond that
quickly because that's immediately what
i think about when i think of the the
greatest memories and moments of my life
and that's why this has been so much fun
is i'm getting to go down memory lane
and those are memories that even if the
business you know blew up tomorrow i
would still have those memories have
have your experiences let's just say at
toms but it could be across the board
and i also want to highlight one thing
for folks which which we
well i glossed over earlier i didn't dig
into so you mentioned all these
businesses that seem to have nothing to
do with one another yeah
but
what are the meta skills that you're
developing you're learning to negotiate
you're learning how to attract and
manage
talent you're learning how to
mitigate or evaluate risk right so even
though the businesses the industries
seem totally unrelated the skills he's
developing do carry from one to the next
perhaps they're not domain specific so
how have your business experiences
affected how
you parent yeah
i'm really glad you asked this question
because it's something that i have a lot
of personal energy around right now
one of the big things is what my wife
have is a monthly calendar date
i say date like it's really not a date
sometimes a battle
but uh it usually ends pretty good
because we drink enough wine to like you
know compromise yeah but but the
calendar is king like if you have a busy
life if you have uh if you're driving
hard in work and family like i mean
the calendar is is the king because
we put things on the calendar they stick
you know that's kind of our thing like
and so we make sure like if i want to
say my goal right now is to spend either
two mornings or two afternoons every
week at home
with our son just me and him not with my
wife just like we either take him on a
hike in the backpack take him to the
beach you know just play in his room
whatever but that's my goal and it will
never ever happen if it's a goal in my
journal it will only happen if in my
case my wife my assistant and i all put
it on the calendar because if it's on
the calendar you're accountable to it
she's like you put this i mean no
meetings and then nothing gets scheduled
so for me the way that we do it is very
much focusing on on on booking things
and and scheduling even little things
which might seem ridiculous like you put
play with your son on the calendar like
that could seem they could come off like
really like i don't know what just
off-putting but the truth is if it's on
the calendar it happens and even if that
seems ridiculous as long as it happens
that's what's the most important thing
so
yeah so
um
that and and
and that's also beyond you know just
time my son like i one thing that i've
always had is a lot of hobbies like i
love to surf i love to snowboard i like
to fly fish i have lots of friends that
like these hobbies we climb together in
the summer and so it's the same thing
like just as i'm planning that business
trip to asia to do a press tour because
we've opened in a lot of stores there if
i'm going to give two weeks of that i'm
also going to make sure i'm giving two
weeks to doing stuff with my buddies and
making sure i stay connected to them
because one thing you find uh as we get
older and you know
especially especially unfortunately this
happens more with men i think than women
is we really lose touch with our guy
friends like we focus on our family we
focus on our jobs and and that's like
one of my dad has always said one of his
biggest regrets as he's had this amazing
life is that like he focused so much
time on his family his jobs and my mom
that he didn't as when he got older in
his 40s and 50s he looked around and he
didn't have guys to really depend on and
so that's another thing that i've always
since learning from my dad that have
placed an importance on it doesn't have
to be a lot of time but it has to be
quality when you do it and and that
usually comes from once again scheduling
it on the calendar yeah if it's not on
the calendar it's not real yeah for sure
if you had a gigantic billboard or side
of a building okay and you could put any
message on it
meaning like getting it out to a lot of
people right what would you put up there
is it's the easiest question you've
asked because it's something that has
been uh
is really been my mantra since i was
19 years old and that is carpe diem
seize the day
because we have no we have very little
control whether we'll be on this planet
tomorrow i mean i could die in a fatal
car crash on the way home and that's it
and so if i don't
literally live every day as if it might
be my last then i am i am i am not doing
a service the life i've been given and
unfortunately that became my mantra
after
um one of my best friends died in a
plane crash when i was 18. and
i realized i could do nothing to get him
back but i could honor his life by
living every day if it was going to be
my last and so every email you've ever
received from me there's never a yours
or a thank you or a truly i sign every
email every letter carpe diem and i have
since i was 19. and you know some people
they don't know me feel like oh it's
kind of a little cheesy that's a little
too optimistic that's a little too much
to think of like seizing every day but i
believe that is a mantra that has served
me so well because i have i have i've
committed my life to doing that like if
i do that then i'm giving the most i can
to what i've been given
ladies and gentlemen blake mikoski oh
thanks
[Applause]
[Music]
good
[Music]
[Music]
you